pour sylvie roy les brosses de métal
pour barbecue c'est fini pourquoi parce
que ce type de bros aurait pu la tuer le
dégueulasse que le gouvernement laisse
encore sur le marché
le 6 juillet dernier elle ressent
d'importantes douleurs au ventre
tellement qu'elle se rend à l'hôpital
maisonneuve rosemont de montréal
après cinq heures d'attenté à l'urgence
elle retourne chez elle sans avoir été
vu par un médecin
deux jours plus tard les douleurs
atroces persiste sylvie roy consulte
l'urgence de l'hôpital de la
cité-de-la-santé à laval et je rencontre
le médecin il m'envoie pas fait une
radiographie et après m'ont fait un
scanner avec contraste et c'est là que y
ont vu qu'il y avait quelque chose
d'assez mon petit intestin
c'est petit quelque chose provenait d'un
souper entre amis
la chirurgienne vient de rencontrer elle
me demande si vous mangez du barbecue
dernièrement le mérite le suspect oui
alors là c'est le cas dadis parce qu'il
ya un fil
de fait qui auraient perforé votre petit
un puck sylvie roy est rapidement père
et le fils de métal est retiré de son
intestin
la médecin la met en garde contre les
brosses à barbecue
parce que des filaments peuvent se
détacher de la brosse et se retrouver
sur la grille lors de la cuisson les
poils de métal se colle à la viande et
peuvent facilement être ingéré ce
chirurgien abonde dans le même sens et
recommande de cesser l'utilisation de
ces brosses et ajoute qu'il ya d'autres
produits sur le marché beaucoup plus
sécuritaire la plupart du temps c'est
pas très dangereux c'est des problèmes
blessures dans la bouche mais quand ça
arrive plus bas ça peut être très
dangereux puis ça que peut même causer
des drones chez ge ou des motards iter
en cinq ans santé canada a dénombré 56k
et dans la majorité d'entre eux il y a
eu des blessures
pour l'instant on pense pas de bannir le
produit parce que dans l'évaluation de
risques qui a été fait par santé canada
on n'a pas été capable de déterminer où
d'associer le risque où les incidents à
un type de brosse en particulier santé
canada recommande d'inspecter les
brosses à barbecue avant de les utiliser
si elles perdent des poils
il faut cesser l'utilisation le
gouvernement canadien travaille
conjointement avec le conseil canadien
des normes et du détail pour rendre le
produit plus sécuritaire
[Musique]